the Google AI engineer uh believes that
uh the Lambda 1 language
natural language system
achieved sentience I don't know if you
paid attention to that I didn't you
didn't but the the general question is
do you think a chatbot do you think a
robot could be conscious
so I mean this answer is slightly
different or very different depending on
whether I kind of follow the assumption
that Consciousness emerges at some point
in physical processing or whether it's
fundamental
um since I've just chosen to stay on the
fundamental Channel
um
I mean then then it's kind of a silly
answer because if Consciousness is
fundamental in in the way I currently
think about it the only way I imagine it
working
um
every physical thing we perceive is the
representation of a conscious experience
so I mean yes that's true true of
everything in the world
um however I would say if that's the
case
even though there's a way in which it's
behaving in similar ways to a human
being
the way it's constructed what it is
actually made of and the physics of it
is so different that I would expect it
to have
an entirely completely non-human
conscious experience
and whether it even feels like a self I
think would be
a big question mark well there's
questions of ethics and yeah is it
capable of suffering is suffering
connected to Consciousness Consciousness
I mean obviously it is it's the it's the
only way you can suffer is
or maybe maybe it's not maybe it's not
maybe it's more connected to self
I would say I mean just on my own use of
these words suffering is only something
that can happen in a conscious
experience right so can robots suffer
if they have a car anything that has a
conscious experience can experience
suffering but do plants suffer in the
same so is there some level
where when we construct
our morals and ethics
that is there a class of conscious
experiences or organisms that are
capable of conscious experience
that we can anthropomorphize
sufficiently such that we give them
rights
yeah I mean this is not an area
that for physics I have spent for me
I have not spent a lot of time thinking
about this most people expect that I
have it's interesting these types of
questions are much less interesting to
me than the other questions and I think
it's because I'm interested in the
physics of things sure I'm I'm somewhat
interested I'm definitely interested in
in ethical questions for human beings
but I have spent very little time
thinking about the implications for
other types of intelligence
I will say that I think the capacity for
suffering
of con of the capacity for suffering of
a conscious system
um goes up with memory and with a sense
of self
so if you take if
if anesthesia only erased your memory
and it didn't actually make you
unconscious you actually experienced
horrifically experienced some surgical
procedure but we could completely wipe
out your memory of it
as
nightmarishes that scenario scenario is
and I'm not suggesting we should ever do
this I would say
if our only option were to erase your
memory of it that would be the more
ethical thing to do than
to have you maintain that memory because
the suffering is then carried
across a longer distance through time
that's presuming that suffering is
unethical
well isn't that what ethics is all about
it's about suffering
I mean I think to me ethics is all about
suffering and well-being and I don't
know what ethics is without that uh
there's different measures of suffering
so having one traumatic event May if you
erase that one traumatic event that
potentially might have
um negative on net consequences for the
growth so that yeah so then it's a
different question but I would
say that memory increases suffering
globally
so that if any moment of suffering
only existed for itself in the present
moment
that is a lesser kind of suffering
than
a suffering that is drawn out over time
through memory so hard to think about
and so yeah I mean in terms of AI
if they're conscious and there's a sense
of self and memory which I think I
actually think you need memory to have a
sense of self
um actually sorry I take that back I
actually think you can have a really
primitive sense of self without memory
um but an AI that is conscious that has
memory and a sense of self
um yeah that that's capable of suffering
absolutely well one of the things
because
you said you haven't really looked into
this area
um because there's so many interesting
things to look into and you're really
focused on the physics side to me the
the the Neuroscience experiments that
you mentioned where there's a difference
between the timing of things that kind
of reveal there's something here yeah to
me working with robots I have robots
that are moving around my home in in
Austin I know I it's a very good
embodied thought experiment but here's
the thing
that
looks like he has a free will
it it looks like it has conscious
experiences
and uh and then I know how it's
programmed and so like I have to go back
and forth
and it's you know this is what I do
you lay on the ground looking up at the
stars thinking about plants and I and I
look at like a robot like well you can
do this with plants too I mean there's
some complex enough behavior that looks
like Free Will from a certain angle and
it makes you wonder it makes you wonder
two things one is there Consciousness
associated with that processing
um and two if there isn't
what does that say about our experience
and
both are our circumstance in nature what
does that say yeah
um but yeah I do I do that with plants
all the time I go back and forth but the
zombie thought experiment now
um at least for me is often presented as
AI because now that's easier as a robot
because that's easier
um
I don't know if it's just because it's
in it's in pop culture now in the form
of films and television shows but it's
it's easier to get to that point of um
contemplation I think by imagining
a robot I don't know why exactly I'm
bothered by philosophers talking about
zombies because
it feels like they're missing it's like
talking about
it's reducing
a a joyful experience so like uh
that's like talking about listen when
you fall in love with somebody yeah the
other person is a zombie you don't you
don't know if they're conscious or not
you're just making presumptions and so
on it's like it says philosophers will
do this kind of things they might as
well be a zombie or you know there's no
such thing as love it's just a mutual
Catholic Economist will reduce love to
some kind of mutual calculation that
minimizes risk and stability over time
right it's like you do all right what I
want to do with each of those people
yeah is I want to take I want to find
every one of those philosophers to talk
about zombies and eventually give them
one of those robots and watch them fall
in love and then and see right how their
understanding of how humble they are by
how little we understand that's the
point of the zombie experiment I mean
sure maybe that's the thought experience
that I mean I I can't say for anything
for zombies is that the thought is that
no so for me I mean I don't like
spending much time on it I think it has
limited use for sure and I unders
understand your your annoyance with it
but for me what's so useful about it is
it gets you to ask the same questions
you're asking when you're looking at
robots
if you just run the experiment and you
say okay you know I'm sitting here with
Lex what if I try to trick myself
what's different about the world if
someone tells me actually he's a robot
is essentially what the zombie
experiment is he's over there he has no
conscious experience he's acting all
Prometheus but there's no experience
there so it gets you to ask some
interesting questions one is
okay when it seems impossible I just
think no that's clear that makes no
sense I can't I can't even imagine that
okay what do I think Consciousness is
responsible for what is consciousness
doing in that in that human over there
that is Lex that I can't
fathom
all of your behavior and everything that
you're you're doing and about without
Consciousness so it gets you to ask this
question and these are this is these are
the questions I begin my book with
um what is consciousness doing it gets
you to ask that question in a deeper way
and then I kind of found this alternate
I don't know if other people have done
this but
I found this alternate use for it which
is even more useful to me which is I'm
able to do it sometimes I'm able to just
sit with someone and and you know get my
imagination going and imagine
there really is no conscious experience
there in that person
and what happened for me the first few
times I was able to do this is it
reminded me exactly of how I feel when I
look at complex plant behavior and other
behaviors in nature where I assume
there's no conscious experience
and
to me it just flips everything it just
flips everything on its head it just
gets you to be able it gets you to be
open to possibilities that you were
closed to before and I think that's
useful